Now, the goal of this unit will be for you to write a PhysicsEngineClass to
manage the interaction of Box2D to your game engine. Now, first things first,
is that we'll need to create a new PhysicsEngineClass and create a global
instance variable for it. Now the core of Box2D simulation is a variable type
called World. Which is used as the main handle to the rest of the APIs. As
such, we need to add a create function to our class. And inside here, create a
new instance of the World object. Note, that typically, the World constructor
takes a vector that represents the gravity of the world. Since now, we're a top
down game, we really don't need a 2D gravity vector. So we're just going to
leave this as 0, 0 for now. Now, the second variable in the constructor, is a
boolean, which tells Box2D, if an object is allowed to sleep or not, given some
time threshold tolerance for the computation. Now, for our purposes, we don't
want to let objects sleep, so we set this, to false. The core of Box2D
simulation is a variable type called World. Now, this is going to be used as
the main handle to the rest of the API's that we're going to use. As such, we
need to add a create Function to our class, and inside of there create an
instance of the World object. So, to move on, go ahead and create an instance
of the World object passing in a vector and a boolean value.